[Musique]
c'était en février dernier le premier
ministre trudeau profitait d'un sommet
de l'union africaine en ethiopie pour
effectuer une tournée du continent et
rencontrer un maximum de chefs d'état
pour nous d'avoir un siège au conseil de
sécurité a dans les années à venir nous
permettra de continuer la campagne
active du canada auprès des dirigeants
de la planète n'aura vraiment duré que
six mois ce qui est très peu selon les
standards onusienne les chances ne sont
pas optimales c'est le moins qu'on
puisse dire
nous allons commencer avec énormément de
retard le ministre canadien des affaires
étrangères reconnaît lui aussi que la
campagne canadienne est arrivée sur le
talent j'aurais mis en avant parce que
certains partenaires et qui voudraient
d'autant que les concurrents du canada
l'irlande et la norvège se sont engagés
dans cette voie il y a plusieurs années
ses deux concurrents ont une très très
bonne réputation sur une des faiblesses
du canada c'est à dire en matière d'
aide extérieure le canada ne dépense que
le tiers des montants qu'il a promis
pour l'aide internationale alors que ses
concurrents norvégien et irlandais font
beaucoup mieux
il est 54 pays africains constitue le
plus grand bloc de vote à prendre effet
le premier ministre aura le rôle du
canada au sein des nations unies a bien
décliner depuis la création des casques
bleus sous l'inspiration du premier
ministre personne lors du conflit du
canal de suez en 1956 le premier
ministre monnet avait utilisé la
présence du canada au sein du conseil de
sécurité pour combattre l'apartheid en
afrique du sud
même chose au cours des années 1990 pour
l'adoption d'un traité contre les usages
des mines antipersonnel et puis l'échec
cuisant de 2010 est survenu portugal 150
canada 32 pour la première fois le
canada a été défait dans sa tentative
d'obtenir une place au sein du conseil
de sécurité
le premier ministre harper n'était pas
un grand partisan des institutions
internationales et plusieurs pays
il avait compris dans le cas actuel bien
au contraire le premier mini c'est
totalement engagée il a une pente très
lourde à remonter mais il ya quand même
un bagage réel du canada
le canada offre sa diversité sa
politique étrangère féministes pour
pousser le conseil de sécurité à faire
les choses il répondu c'est que nous on
serait prêt à mettre l'épaule à la roue
pour justement réinventer le
multilatéralisme amitié est réaliste et
plus inclusif qui s'attaque aux
inégalités et qui donne une voix que le
mans depuis les années 1990 le canada ne
jouit plus de son aura deux défenseurs
de la paix dans le monde
encore récemment sa participation à la
mission au mali a été jugé trop brève
est trop modeste
le vote de demain révélera l'ampleur des
dégâts ou pas c'est sylvain desjardins
radio canada montréal